[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande votre attention si nous
sommes ici ce soir c'est qu'il y a une
bonne raison je ne viens pas vendredi
réveil
toujours pas payé mais pourtant c'est de
trouver là-haut la mission
[Musique]
dans les moments difficiles éloigner les
doutes et poursuivre sa route les vit
dans les Belges de LEGO
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de ces rencontres qui ont changé votre
vie
pour nous ce sont nos instruments de
musique complètement différents qui nous
ont fait nous rencontrer
nous sommes un soir de septembre 2016
lors d'une jambe alors une jambe c'est
le rendez-vous du musicien une scène un
lieu tu viens avec ton instrument de
musique et puis tu vas partager jouer
avec d'autres musiciens que tu ne
connais pas forcément en fait c'est le
lieu typique pour faire des connexions
et ce soir là quand j'entends David
il y a des choses qui se passent
d'expliquer à textes
en réalité il y a eu un lien très fort
entre nous une sorte d'interaction
inexplicable j'ai senti que musicalement
visionnait que nous instruments de
musique se capter une sorte d'alchimie
comme si nous avions joué des milliers
de fois ensemble
et puis nous avons commencé à discuter
et nous nous sommes rendus compte que
indépendamment l'un de l'autre Noémie et
moi avions choisi de sortir de nos
sentiers battus
les flûtes amérindiennes que Noémie joue
sont depuis plus de 4000 ans utilisés
dans des cérémonies et des rituels des
peuples premiers d’amérique Noémie les a
extraites de leur milieu d'origine afin
de les proposer aux musiques du globe
alors bien sûr des musiques allant de la
musique zen au Zouk
tandis que le chat manstick l'instrument
que David utilise lui est un instrument
très très rare et d'autant plus moderne
puisqu'il a été créé en 1969 en
Californie
alors notre duo plutôt atypique et très
différent
aux yeux de l'industrie musicale il
rentre dans aucune case
moi je dirais que le duo est Vaiana
rentre dans la case des incasable
mais un peu importe en fait parce que
nous sommes ce que nous sommes nous
composons avec ce que nous sommes et
nous proposons ce que nous sommes la
somme de deux univers distincts et
pourtant complémentaire
et nous voyons qu'en cultivons nos
différences
nous nous rendons compte qu'elle nous
apprennent énormément sur nous-mêmes et
lorsque nous les mettons en commun ces
mêmes différences deviennent nos forces
alors merci merci à la vie de nous faire
chacun différent parce qu'en passant par
cette expérience et bien pour nous on se
rend compte que cette ouverture vers le
monde cette ouverture vers l'autre
et bien c'est un des chemins qui mènera
vers un meilleur avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci la route est longue et qu'au fond
aucun bonheur
[Musique]
le meilleur est le parvenir
ça nous prendra du temps car nous sommes
différents
mais j'ai le sentiment que le meilleur
reste à venir
à toi qui suis le fond de ton cœur
[Musique]
le meilleur
ta
manière sur
les mondes aucune traite pour tes rêves
puis les chaque seconde
[Musique]
mon rêve d'un nouveau monde le meilleur
est à venir ça nous prendra du temps car
nous sommes différents
j'ai le sentiment que le meilleur espace
[Musique]
quoi qu'on ne peut pas y arriver sont
les deux plus grands frérot qui nous
empêche d'avancer on aura voulu décision
de danser la fatalité on finit par céder
à la rivalité et tous nos espoirs sont
partis en fumée mais
si chacun est-il sonotentricité
[Musique]
il y aura un faiblesse pour
petits et grands pour les utopistes et
les gens moins de polémique et bien plus
de conscience une bonne vibrations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci la route est longue et qu'au fond
nos coeurs
mon rêve d'un nouveau monde le meilleur
est parvenir
ça nous prendra du temps
car nous sommes différents
j'ai le sentiment que le meilleur
esclave venir
la route est longue
pour nos parents de nouveau
mon meilleur est à venir ça nous prendra
du temps
car nous sommes griffons
j'ai le sentiment que le meilleur
escarte
je suis la route est longueur
[Musique]
ça nous prendra
car nous sommes différents
j'ai le sentiment que le meilleur reste
avec lui que le meilleur esclave que le
meilleur reste à venir que le meilleur
reste à venir que le meilleur reste car
que le meilleur restable libre que le
meilleur reste à venir que le meilleur
reste à venir que le meilleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]